president trump is once again spreading
misinformation about the pandemic
retweeting conspiracy theories
and promoting unproven drugs yesterday
spent most of his coronavirus briefing
defending things he'd retweeted that
directly counter his own comments and
also spent time wondering out loud why
dr anthony fauci has higher approval
ratings than he does
now paula reed has more on this story
from the white house
president trump was back to his usual
ways at tuesday's press briefing
sparring with reporters and pushing the
controversial drug hydroxychloroquine
i think it's become very political i
happen to believe in it i would take it
as you know i took it for a 14-day
period
and i'm here right but his own
fda cautions against using the drug to
treat kovid
warning of serious heart rhythm problems
the president also defended his decision
to retweet this video which promotes the
drug
we're america's front line doctors
twitter facebook and youtube all deleted
the video for making false claims about
kovid
including that there's a cure for the
virus and that masks are not necessary
neither of which are true and contradict
the administration's own guidance
i think they're very respected doctors
there was a woman who was spectacular in
her
statements about it actually used to
these medications but that woman has
also made videos saying things like
doctors make medicine using dna from
aliens
i thought her voice was an important
voice but i know nothing about her
the president also retweeted an attack
on dr fauci
but he continues to insist the two have
a great relationship
he's got a very good approval rating and
i like that even as he wondered aloud
why he wasn't as popular as the top
doctor
dr fauci and dr burks also highly
thought of and yet they're highly
thought of but nobody likes me
it can only be my personality in an
interview out this morning president
trump revealed
that he has not confronted russian
president vladimir putin
over intelligence indicating that russia
paid the taliban to kill u.s troops
democrats have seized on this suggesting
that this
is evidence that the president will not
challenge putin
even when u.s lives are at stake jerica
paula thank you